the best players always followed the
best players they want to be in the top
of the game because they are the ones
they are there you know you cannot rest
or sleep because the other one can pass
you if you want to be a football player
or if you want to be engineering or
whatever you want to be dedicate
yourself you know work hard it's not
about the money it's about the passion
for me this is the most important thing
need motivation watched our town with
believe nation
what's that believe nation in seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack on chewing today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up poor
to being expelled from school to being
diagnosed with a racing heart which
almost ended his football career to
becoming one of the highest-paid and
most successful athletes in the world is
Cristiano Ronaldo and here's my take on
his top ten Rose a success volume to
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work on your talent hard work or
talent talents times you don't have
talent forget it but of course if you
have talent and if you work hard
dedicate yourself you will be much
better but of course the talent it's the
main word if you don't have talent you
can work whatever you want you're never
going to be a great player but I have to
mention talent when using Manchester I
saw you you knew you wasn't complete
what did you do what you doing but when
everybody go inside finish training what
were you doing I learned I learn on to
be better and better to be around the
best players in the world so but if you
you make the two things talent with a
hot work hard you can be a huge player
and this is my my heading and I think
I'm I mean that role
the Spanish championship something
special for its Patrick goal and a
landmark goal for Real Madrid Jerry well
I'll tell you what Rob you're not gonna
see much better goals than that what a
hat-trick of what a third goal
[Applause]
believable bourbon is skill the par the
technique rule number two
maintain a high level of excellence
being number one on Instagram on Twitter
on Facebook the best the highest-paid
everything how much do you pay for that
how much do you give for that how much
do you train for that
well this dedication and hard work this
is my my words to the decades myself
under percent every time to be the
position that I am today is not one year
it's ten years twelve years you know to
maintain my level it's it's make me feel
proud as you mentioned histogram Twitter
Facebook the number one of course I feel
proud for that but for me the most
important it's to maintain my level in
the pitch you know to play good to score
goals to assistance to win trophies and
this is what I wanna keep continuing to
do it because is what I love to do it is
to play football and maintain my my fans
and my supporters happy you have to
dedicate yourself and the percent it
doesn't mean that many hours you train
but the way your training your
dedication you can haven't training only
one hour but you give everything for
that to achieve your goals
so this is what I tried to do it in it
in the trainings in the games try to be
better in better and my job and for the
last seven eight years I think I
maintain my level in the same way so
this has made me feel proud and I I will
continue to work hard to maintain that
level
relationship is non-existent with the
Spanish media the nominees brilliant
well watch out
Manchester United on Wednesday a game
for big emotions it will be for
Cristiano Ronaldo he's almost in a
position here if he wants to play he
plays and he scores a fabulous girl rule
number three compete to be the best the
level that I am is like in other sports
formula wanna NBA the best players
always followed the best players they
wanna be in the top of the game because
they are the ones they are there you
know you cannot rest or sleep because
the other one can pass you of course we
fight with everyone with the Neymar with
the messy with live and offski we dig
way in you know with the top of the best
players in the world so I mean this is
not fighting but it's it's it's hard
it's healthy you know how compressions
is healthy and we fight you know to be
the best this is why it's my main point
it's my motivation is to be better than
them than them here after here
[Applause]
rule number four persevere it may not
have been the easiest of starts at
Sporting Lisbon but by the age of 16
were now that had broken into the first
team and was already earning plaudits
for his performances in fact the likes
of Inter Milan Arsenal and Liverpool
were all set to be interested and then
they came up against a certain
Manchester United and the rest as they
say is history he is going to be one of
the worst nightmare
death to the big panther of all england
are going committed ronaldo
eighteen-years-old cost the reds 12 and
a quarter million from Sporting Lisbon
he was part of the Lisbon team who
defeated the Premiership champions 3-1
in a friendly last week and the United
players were so impressed by him they
pleaded with Ferguson to seal the deal
we came up against each other virtually
every day in training it was very very
difficult to get the ball off him he was
brilliant in the air it was very very
difficult to market was definitely the
best winger that I played again
Christiano struggled at first to adapt
to the culture the weather the nights
going dark quickly he was shy he didn't
speak the language with referees with
opposition defenders he handled
everything in his stride because I think
he had this vision that this is why I
had to do Cristiano Ronaldo so I wait
we used to get kicked every day in
trains used to get kicks everyday in the
Premier League but he never used to
bother in your sock dolls early years at
once unite is particularly the way that
strikes folks and wants a stirring I
think may that they help to become one
of the best players in the world you
have the ability to practice and
practice for hours and hours on end
after training just in the Cristiano
Ronaldo owner zero is called for this
camp Yuri the pornography Newton and a
second attempt or the advantage or
Colunga last repertory Cristiano Ronaldo
rule number five surround yourself with
great people how you make the balance
it's easy when you work when you work
with the best team in the world because
I think I'm my team the guys would have
the best team in the world in my opinion
yes they work hard like me outside the
football of course some business is
something that I liked it and I in the
future I can see myself in that position
but now as you know I have to focus more
in a football because this is my my job
but outside of football I have a
fantastic team the guys in the specific
areas that take care of me and I'm so
blessed for that and I feel of course
happy for that because I have
unbelievable team do you look to - did
the spreadsheets yourselves do you go to
like to ask the managers how business is
going or your source our life - no yeah
you do yes it's important and it's you
know when something have your name I
think
should have interesting to know all the
things going going on
so not all about my shoes but all the
products as you say the hotels plan Nike
product very nice blanket blanket got
one yes they add for many things we have
so of course we are in new control as I
said before have a fantastic team that
they give me the information about
everything I'm not under % worry what
the things going on because I trust in
my people so this is why we we have a
fantastic team and of course I'm so
happy with my team to Kathy era but the
flip over the top
PK always looks the ball big chance for
a second here Cristiano Ronaldo takes
his time still got time so there
this is great skill flex it with the
back of his heel over the top with your
pick and what a fantastic piece of scalp
from Ronaldo steadies himself up and
they're buying off the food of the
goalkeeper Victor Valdes and into the
back of the net rule number six
learn from your defeats his kiss vegan
adore do it here store annot no cheaper
there oh no me gusta bear their burden
la Vida rock a costumer Sugino todo el
ganar siempre no es verdad si part a
specimen Dimitra bajo paribas a seguro
que es una persona ganador a yoga no
mask appeared Oh
pero yo tendon tear are las cosas buenas
kkona / demos a cosas importantes de en
que que tear our condo podemos algo y
por ESO es que tener que nos torna
message parentage Colavito
nel football yo policies on a persona
chaos scepter blast a hot - why now
nezam cuando por que se que Tamia Brenda
mucho coins coming elapsed show with the
clearing head only as far as de Maria
50 goes up again for Cristiano Ronaldo
many times does he go to the
out of trouble rule number seven have a
winner's mentality on the pitch what
would you say has been your greatest
achievement so far on and off the pitch
actually inside the pitch here inside
the pitch is always the most important
is to win trophies because you will work
10 11 months if you don't win nothing
it's it's empty you know and I like to
win trophies collective and individual
because I work hard for that outside the
pitch it's to have the family that I
have and the friends that I have and to
be try to be the most happy person in
worlds
[Applause]
brilliantly done by Ronaldo he's willing
free of all yellow shirts here it's
Cristiano Ronaldo
let's go
magnificent go
and in that moment creates a real Madrid
club record the first player in the long
illustrious history of Real Madrid to
score and he's opening for League
matches and it was brilliant
rule number eight my personal favourite
believe anything is possible how to be
number one how to achieve all your goals
tell them the secret heart please try to
motivate the children and those well
don't exist secret here the secret zone
exists exists hard work dedication be
obsessed to be something something in a
life and follow their dreams I think if
you want to be a football player of if
you want to be engineering or whatever
you want to be dedicate yourself you
know work hard you know and believe in
you I think this is the main words not
just a kids want to be a Cristiano
Ronaldo but anything it can be you know
work hard it's I think it's it's the
main work and the dream to believe in
that everything is possible in a life
most all but one of their games
with a cocky but a long time to see that
Sergio Alvarez and at the same end where
Ronaldo scored from a long-range
free-kick at the weekend against Real
Sociedad another goalkeeper is deceived
rule number nine enjoy the moment
[Applause]
not about the money is about the passion
only this is the most important thing to
be in my shoes is not cz but I'm not I'm
not to play I'm feel happy all this
happened because the reason the reason
is I'm unbelievable inside the pitch in
my mind not just this year but always
I'm always the best basically I win
everything
in terms of individual and collective oh
my rival don't exist here in football
now it's it's just again you want to do
it is best for his club for his national
team and I want to do it the same we
share all the time the same places so I
have a good relationship with it
wanna carry on the last five six years
more and then we will decide what I'm
gonna do it this moment I'm so glad and
happy here and real madrid's
but as I say many many times the future
nobody knows he cannot know what reality
each of our individual season have both
very good things that everybody should
have as footballers at least so let's
get on some model how long we got to see
a Lafayette miss Kelly if the book is so
modest Carol I'm still Mao's his left
foot is really good and I'd like to
[Applause]
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun okay
okay
[Music]
my photo okay Holly another ciao Patera
footage Tom oh it's awesome particularly
nice hey you know what's it matter did
not realize it now will give I know that
no oh yeah
probably another does me notice Oh
llamada tus amigas a chow vámonos a la
vez para back lucky us address
tropic lucky donde la tienda for Maria
Jeremy parfumerie Oh No todo bien
illegal we perfume Cristiano you
Cristiano Ronaldo legacy no let go
I care a lot of collage for myself but I
have a handle on the various Acapulco
Patroni
[Music]
well how much photos yeah I looked at
myself ponzu soy pilot
[Music]
I mean there's a muchos anos at the
manse
always filming please come on it was
let's go no even the guys left left his
job to take a picture away from him
again he shoots
bobsleigh a second goal
beautiful here
we knew it was a tough game
but two fabulous strikes that one
through the goalkeeper my despair load
in support now I've got three very
special Cristiano Ronaldo bonus clips on
how to be patient find your motivation
and be passionate but before that I want
to know what did you learn from this
video what was the single biggest
takeaway that you're going to apply
somehow to your life or your business
what stood out leave it down the
comments below when you write it down
you're much more likely to actually take
action on it so put it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
superbee para um ganador que su Poneke
adoptable the final dela champions oh
sui-lan you know
pero de la temporada parity lo peor
c'est la verdad que Frio momentum
complicado para me free momento bueno
Malo digamos esteem porque yo estaba con
illusion cakey Amish llegar my mess
Laiho pero de ville de la chef consensus
cap asado and habla de los Prados
Calvinism and huevos
when I keep on crustacean internal or
diferente by no Luisito no sassy dunal
Inga Hector for Vista Zaki Hezbollah
room poco you must record the production
blue in Manchester much promoters
anguish you know I got nada nada y
despues vo las casas más importantes que
quiero decir que hace que a que seguir
trabajando coalition Christa Club
seguramente wagon are not champagnes you
basically want everything almost
but like question what keeps you
motivated so you just keep going keeps
going goals keep waiting it's good
question my motivation it's always to
play to play football this is what I
like to do I love to play to play
football and I am I feel able you know
to keep carry on with my job to score
goals to entertain the people my friends
especially my friends because they they
always support me I want to carry on I
feel good well it's hard it's hard to
say what I'm gonna do in the future
but one thing that I'm sure it's I like
to leave the present the present is good
I know I'm not gonna be young for for
all life maybe I'm gonna play a few
years more I will feel good but after
have many too many things to do I don't
look myself right now to be a coach okay
I don't I don't think so but you know
with the hate you change you start to
get new habits maybe I don't know but
right now I don't see myself to be a
coach I will I will be in other things
relate with with the football but not
coach I think so
hello this
for children of Syria we know that you
have been suffering a lot I am a very
famous player but you are the true
heroes don't lose your hope the world is
with you we care about you I am with you
walked our Z melanoma at Yalta
what's your name your name yota
Oh Sonia is jogador dead
[Music]
follow me outside
was it
[Music]
it's believed in your capacities war
card dedicate yourself on the percent
and dreamed belief all the time believe
that say say sneaky friend Oh God spoons
basket was full on staff principal to
the mount active evolve even mr. pink
Easter not a great event to tell a
banana to speech
[Music]
[Laughter]
with flesh this one is the prevalent and
to physically manage the sharpest from
each dimension we'll give it a shot
instead of advanced form of sugar
shakers I'd love to see you Tommy for
that
[Music]
deviation fake mister give me Markham
what's a success genetics answers like
income Boston Garden Miguel with mom
Miguel and the fundo callosum to meme
felishj inverse exists in this pretty
much one little small medium the most
important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details